I was going brothers - hey you're
probably like you know the brofist is
out on Steam right now today you're here
- yeah why are you here today
yes look at us just walking around what
you love everything creepy um
okay so the game is out on PC we wanted
to add some extra stuff so we have co-op
so you can play with a controller the
way we really intended the game from the
beginning there's also a Christmas map I
don't know if you saw it but we're not
gonna play it we're gonna play highway
frenzy like the good old days I'll be my
good ol safe so for this one good old
credit pack okay listen you know what
it's Christmas I'll be Stefano so all
the characters got new skins so if
you're out great you died right away if
you're an old school favor I find you'll
recognize Stefano it's really cool
dammit as a character I like your
Christmas outfit very very pretty we had
this thing in that iOS version oh god
damn dogs that if you shake I guess that
doesn't work nevermind okay you have X&Y
Edgar's parts and to serve on Miami
they're pretty good it's really fun to
do co-op in the game I didn't know like
we didn't know how well it would work
oh God yeah it it is fun oh God oh yeah
oh my god you inside I forgot about that
I'm so stupid alright let's keep going
because you have the punks to save you
but now you have each other to save
I think we can actually finish this
level there aren't some other new things
that I want to show up later but I'm not
honestly sure if we can do this
don't jump ahead you almost killed me I
I told you not to jump on my head when
you're it don't dive okay okay okay I'm
responding once again ever again okay
thank you so much for your having my
cover front okay don't go there
all right see you later I'm sure you're
gonna make it back well we're playing
like the hack version of like we have
all the unlocks there's no point yes
okay this part is tricky I'm gonna you
should use Edgar parts X there you go
but not and you're fine don't worry your
back here they're back in on the broad
track
all right we're halfway there we can do
this thank you yes you're welcome
see you later Marcia ah okay I got my
bro fist attack
did you just jump jump good job you try
it's okay I I try not to wake you about
what what are you gonna do all right
what do you get this game is all about
teamwork guessing you can clearly see
don't you there are times in this game
to jam and there's times in this game
that you Jim don't worry don't worry
buddy all the time all right all right
all right
am I too fast I'm sorry I didn't mean to
okay I go into fabulous mode I'm so
emoji bro look at this dark mode all the
way I'm dark stock now because I'm
playing as
nice okay yeah we're totally doing no he
said they're doing they're hopeful oh no
it's okay
don't worry you'll you're back back oh
god oh god oh god
oh don't time yeah I look so awesome I
want that hi you have that happen in
gold white if it's not gold then don't
I'm alright so fine I only ask oh yeah
why did you jump up and at me what Wow
I see how it is got a tour get out come
it's work gun its work attack okay so
another thing once so once he beat the
whole level you unlock bug mode in the
regular game or whatever
we still have pug mode but it's a bit
different now it's a little easier since
we're in pug mode Rica is my asset guy
yeah if you go to like you see my only
has one night some fun mode is so hard
it's ridiculously out but it's really
fun challenging in in a fun way you have
to take it very slow yeah but I like
that
you need the teamwork in the peg love
for sure Oh God I'm waiting for you
there you go oh god you run you run
reverse psychology good teamwork our
teamwork is clearly showing here okay I
can do this
I don't need I'm just getting you nice
fun there you go okay
I know do you oh you ruined me every
time you keep like standing as I jump on
you there you go
saved your life saved your life right
there you're welcome I did yes and yes
filling it out and doing is killing it
everyone yes yes don't slam don't slam
my okay all right oh god damn it
all right five more might be a long
rehab team I mean it okay see that's the
problem when you jump on each other what
you should take that route you should go
downstairs
does it go down no no that's exactly how
I meant okay it's fun again oh god my
and here's happy buddy
yeah we've never made it this far this
okay you are crazy
oh man clearly wait for Mama to kill
herself okay
now like that now if you hold down jump
you jump better it's a just yeah yeah
yeah let me jump on you there you go
okay now we're gonna run don't worry
we're just gonna survive stay on the
other platform other player that was no
no okay
it's okay I just okay go left don't
stand on the six button there we go
okay now go all way free here okay I
take the easy ride you take the high
reps okay Oh Alec Alec are you
yeah alright team right there yeah yeah
we never made it this one we're worried
it stops ups at that oh Jesus Christ
okay alright we can do this 100% okay
alright you ready yeah yeah
I'm careful so careful so careful what
how did you die wait stay there this is
clearly part of the gameplay no damn it
alright we're playing a different
version of the game that's why that
happened god dammit
I'm fine fine we're not destined to do
pokémon but there is there is the
Christmas level but I think we're gonna
say that for another time we can do well
let's do the lever bus so all
the characters got new skins punk and I
mean joke mode is Turkey for Christmas
which makes sense I'm gonna play as him
let's do this we look so good together
mmm-hmm hey don't jump on me mmm-hmm
ride me right it's our key yes
you're okay let's not get worried about
this battle ever
okay so watch out for his quick scopes
or no scopes I mean course of course
there you go
I'll hit him nailed it so what happens
like a turkey go into dunk mode I become
family yeah I like a bend it bend what
does the name Chen's that name
knowing you 600 that's why you think you
got quickscope that's insta kill all
right we can do this are you gonna frisk
oh oh god I've gotta have one life yeah
BAM best friend Stefano comes out I'm
sorry I just want it to be noticed I
love it so much we're downloading an app
to go to the US he's actually a nice
person you're right I don't know I
became turkey or thing or thing all
right so that's a little piece of
pedophile legend of the brofist on
computer it's available on PC and Mac
I'm really really proud of this game cuz
it's it really feels complete now and
it's a lot of fun with co-op right so go
check it out it's a we really wanted to
add more stuff so if you haven't it if
you own the game already it leads to get
some more stuff you could have it on PC
and you a co-op doesn't really make
sense for iOS so good stuff check it out
really appreciating the support and I'm
just so proud of our minds for doing
such a great job in this game so
for now I'll do the Christmas one in
another one but that's all for now
nobody no stay awesome breath